dude's trying to uh get ready after the
show oh yeah yeah these were coming up
what am i what am i i was like i'm like
bro if you don't get out of my face he
was like what am i doing
pictures of the girls my dude what's my
girl man like well do you
probably think she's a twin wait this is
this is so we got a rainbow yeah
i found some [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up bam look at them hold the
[ __ ] up
they look great we want to make it
reality dingus
[Applause]
do they not look good there i'm not
asking them i like them we all
performing
but my sock's got holes in them oh my
god
something always has to happen you look
like you're right but but your bell can
surprisingly
sing especially especially like while
alternative song came in the car
oh it was under oath god that was great
yeah i was feeling it dude i was like
[ __ ] yeah i don't know uh it was uh
high above me she's so hot no no no
that's not the one
that we were driving to the airport oh
yeah underwrap
yeah that was dude all right what's
wrong so we got a new segment rate my
state
people send submissions they send the
submission to thick boy ride
at gmail.com if you want to be pitched
uh
featured on rate my state here's amanda
what do we know about amanda from
ontario canada shout out to canada
yeah mother of three a nursing school
boy and she looks like the kids are
lucky
after three the kids are lucky well
here's the thing we know amanda getting
it in because she's 24. she's 25
yeah and she's a mom of three already so
she's she is so you know she's got it
like that
yeah i'm amanda now this is ontario
canada
ontario before i give her a rating let
me show me where ontario's at pretty
sure ontario's
uh is it the east east coast pretty sure
canada is so [ __ ] big man i don't
know
dude canada's locked the [ __ ] down
so yes okay so it's east
wow i think wow it's next to quebec
ottawa okay ottawa's in ontario okay i
know where that's at now
it's in the ottawa is kind of near
toronto
you say don't worry about it she got the
maple maple leaf hitters out the front
yeah
she's a mother of three but again is
this it or is it another picture just a
two
bro you should we can't see her cause
she's covering her face right there look
at her right there oh yeah she's a
beautiful face
i didn't see it i would say she is
ontario eight
okay what'd you give her she better i
was gonna give her a nine okay i'll give
her a tarot nine
i get 8.3 she got the maple leaf
[ __ ] hitters dude what do you think
her la rating would be
l.a christian good call
no she's she's a seven seven la that
body that mommy possibly i saw that
today in pilates
i give it like a six
no she's at least a seminal that behind
cause i'm an la-6
and she's tatted up she's that and she
has her [ __ ] together yeah throw that in
she's a nurse in school
beast mama three oh yeah she got three
oh my gosh she got kids
in the room and for her to be a seven in
la
that's great you're right them tits make
her seven let's be real here
i mean that's all she has and she has
those piercing blue eyes probably a
positive attitude
probably super nice from canada and i
love that has a car
i love that honey blonde kind of
hairstyle i love that those are
highlights
highlights yeah set of lipsticks
honeycomb
dude she yeah she she's a stone cold la7
i'd say ontario eight or nine la7 what
did that honeycomb block bro you just
saved their hair after cereal
she got them sugar smacked eyes she got
that kool-aid smile she got the fruity
loose flips
she got them fruity pebble tips
you describe her like y'all want to
describe it
you got some coco chris titties down i
got them
toast crunch teeth what
she got that raisin bran hairline
what the [ __ ] and she got nutrients
so the johnny m rate my state johnny m's
from indiana
and he's he says he's in la three oh
papa i disagree
just this he hired me no i gotta know
how i don't know how old he is this is
the only picture
he has three of them there oh he's a
left
yeah yeah the other guy didn't have a
hand
oh it was oh my bad
it's a strong hand
you look at that picture i got to know
how old he's obviously 20
mid 20s that would help if we had age
he's also a [ __ ]
veteran you [ __ ] he says l.a
definitely hired an la3 he looks like a
dime piece there that other one
go the other one but this is that the
boxing match though still i like my yeah
oh
just being a veteran out of pure respect
can't give him lower than a five
no he's above a five
well in indiana that first picture in
the uniform i'm gonna give him an
eight that's an indiana a yeah yeah
doesn't it he's at la
i'd say five point five
point five five point five five and a
half bouncing off you five and a half
yeah yeah i give him la five and a half
well we don't even know his height uh
you know because la is big out here in
height no so send in like your
everything all your descriptions height
weight
all that stuff i don't need your weight
yeah i need you i would like your weight
well the weight size too no i just went
are we getting measurements
he's like well now now i'm 5 10.
well you are la2 because we're super
superficial
i know you just said it old ass kids
yeah i'm five eight four hundred
they're falling on hard times from high
school i just sat next to brenda shaw
and j
shot so what so age weight
height yeah what else that does that's
it
i give him an la five and a half like
chappelle indiana indiana
heart eight especially that picture
strong eight strong eight
honest eight i'm gonna give him a six
cause he's a boxer
all good yeah la-6 yeah what do you what
han kat what are you giving oh la-6 i
don't you talking about
indiana i was like i give him an la-6
la-6 yeah that's fair
yeah he's in that range though
shout out to johnny shout out johnny
this is shannon samuels
okay shannon let's see what she
oh yeah i didn't think shannon was gonna
look like that he was a guy he looked
like an older version of stevie that's
the situation you're right
stevie's future yeah i'm very excited
now this guy will
not pass the drug test and he has
tattoos 47.
he's tattooed clearly from the 90s
yeah that mortal kombat tattoo does does
his tattoo say six
nine in it or is it like an infinity
yeah that's that old
cancer sign thing or whatever right i
thought it was like is that the infinity
sign
i think it's like cancer the horoscope
yeah
either that or capricorn somebody this
this this boy is bodied up brought it up
and he's 47 father of one
yeah uh an elderly seven lewis st louis
he's a nine he's a nine lewis yeah he
come here
he's seven i
look at those obliques down to the dick
root
he's a seven eight i said seven in l.a
oh he would kill the game in l.a seven
he totally would we don't know his
height
i mean father he's a dad too yeah i'm
gonna give him a whole i'm gonna give
him a st
louis heart eight maybe a nine depending
on what he's wearing
i'll give him an la7 at 47. perfect
that's perfect yeah
i got the same thing saint louis nine my
boy's bodied up look at his chest
no what you got chapelle uh st louis uh
nine i give him an la eight
that's fair okay
saint louis last one shyla hopefully
it's a girl
i would imagine i thought shannon
hawaii hawaiian doesn't live in hawaii
hawaiian
mom of three boys she looks so friendly
i know her
and then oh damn girl okay don't hurt
him now in that dress she's got the
moana tits at the top
[Laughter]
she's 30 mom of three that's the thing
dude mama of three
yeah that does somebody's body yeah yeah
oh i don't so yeah we don't know where
she lives dude
that would help i don't know yeah let's
say she's white yeah
she's hawaiian so maybe she grew up
there i haven't been to hawaii there's
been a while i've never been in hawaii
either we're supposed to be on i'm gonna
go to hawaii
what's up i'm about to go to hawaii for
what in may for stevie's birthday
you're taking him to hawaii yeah was his
birthday the twenty uh
the 19th i knew i was i was close you're
very close are we in houston
now steve like had a great day with kat
with alpacas i'm like
bro bro you got one more save this for
your facebook stephen
i don't want to see you another [ __ ]
alpaca
he said he said six pictures of alpacas
i'm like dude back to back to back to
back
no one said anything after the first one
he left the first one like five minutes
he said that one i said i said justin
got teeth like an alpaca
remember that i didn't want to laugh
just go we'll continue with the
statement so but then i was like all
right one pick of an alpaca all
set bubba six and then
the his comments were the same as like a
parent would say oh yeah like the cash
yeah he's like
cat's fun but i think this alpaca's
taking my heart
it was so [ __ ] and no one replied
no one replied and he kept sending him i
was like oh no i i
i gave the ha ha are you getting it hold
on what did blow the bell post to
francis feel like
oh gotcha this is me talking [ __ ] all
right cool oh
um yeah it was interesting man stevie
posted like a straight up dad
he was lit from alpacas
who posted cat yeah i saw this
i think still stevie put it on his page
oh no yes steve you put it on his put it
on his page
what did what did cat say though let me
let's finish that often
i get the alpaca hype hold up now
and then let me see our pictures okay
tina eat your food is that from napoleon
dynamite yeah teen nature teenager
quesadilla
right it was enchiladas
yeah tina yeah so here's enchiladas
who's in childhood
here's something about alpaca's cat and
stevie should probably look this up look
at
this
um the thing is
another picture of just the alpaca
i said no i said this picture i zoomed
down my package and look at justin's
teeth
zooming on that out back his teeth see
my guy i mean fight back at least i know
he can't even fight
that group chat is the arena we light
each other up
man we don't respond to that he was like
we'll fight oh yeah
he's dead
uh in palmdale the farm is sweetwater
alpaca farm
how far is that uh maybe 45 minutes from
l.a
oh not very far terrible it isn't bad
we're a bunch of kids there
uh no there was another couple who came
before
all grown adults grown adults
interesting yeah right
loving the alpacas here's here's a
little fact about alpacas i looked more
into it
because uh steve was talking about
buying alpaca the thing about alpacas
is uh they're real cheap to buy but then
they're a beast to maintain so
everyone's trying to give out packers
away oh you have to have two of them
because they're social
animals if there's just one it gets
depressed
so you gotta get two you gotta get two
and you gotta [ __ ] eat like
a certain amount of acres to have them
roam around it you know stevie does
steve you wanna say i wanna buy an
outback that's a bad investment bubble
you gotta have two
anything each other house at home now
i've never seen him happier in my life
though
he loves alpaca he loves alpacas i can't
from just from the group tags yeah he's
[ __ ] no like when you
the six pictures we saw when you see him
in a vicinity of an alpaca
like he changes he becomes like this
middle-aged mother maybe maybe it's like
his spirit and like gets his i think it
is
i really should buy one bring it on the
planes and [ __ ] you can do that
if you get no they don't
yeah they had a bunch of stuff on a
plane yeah they tried to bring them on
they try to be on pizza yeah peacock
there it is
i've heard of squirrels before but now
you can't do it it's only dogs
only dogs yeah really you don't even see
dogs at the airport anymore
people are chilling out on that yeah
even that you have to have like a
certain
type of dog too because there are
certain airlines that won't let pitbulls
on
that's [ __ ] up man yeah pitbulls are
great i heard
people like attacked a kid face in an
airplane
really bad yeah what we can't have that
hey that
we didn't give that hawaiian moana honey
let's finish up the ratings oh yeah i'm
sorry uh i've got eight in hawaii you're
on that warm luke bath you've been
hawaii
you ever seen that hawaiian eight no
dude
okay and she's not going
she's pretty though man she's really
pretty again the mama three gets me man
hawaiian are you gonna stand by yeah
i've never been i've never been hawaii
either i'm gonna give a hawaii
i'll give her a macadamia nut seven
what is that
i give her i give her a i give her a la
seven i give her a hawaii eight
i'm not gonna be mean okay well what'd
you give her in la
i was gonna say seven i'll say that yeah
she's pretty hot man dude she's she's a
naples nine
those old dudes would be all over her
dude bro we saw
so many how old is old 65 and above
i'm sorry that's the average age 665 and
there's mommy money down there i'm young
girl stupid looking
old dudes dude we rented an explorer
people were making friends older dudes
those older dudes have younger women out
there man
good for them that factory right away
you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song